PROFESSOR: The stable match
problem that we just looked at
is one example of a
bipartite matching problem.
So the setup with a
bipartite matching problem
is you've got a simple graph.
And the vertices are
split into two groups,
as in the stable
matching problem,
we can call them the girls
and the boys, the G and the b.
So the definition
of a bipartite graph
is a graph where there
are some vertices called
the left vertices and a
disjoint set of vertices
called the right vertices.
And every vertex is
either left or right.
And edges only go between a
left vertex and a right vertex.
Now, in this case,
the matching problem
that we want to
consider is that there
is a specification
that each girl is
willing to be paired
with certain boys,
but not all of them.
So we can specify that
by adding edges where,
if this is the first
girl on the list,
and she is willing to be
paired with the second boy
and the last boy.
And that's what those
two edges indicate.
So edges are signaling
compatibility constraints
on matching up the
girls and the boys.
And what we're
trying to accomplish
is getting all of the girls
matched with a unique boy--
match each girl to a
unique compatible boy.
So there's an
example of a match,
where there is one highlighted
magenta edge out of each girl.
And they go to different boys.
So formally, we want a
bijection from the girls
to the boys that follows edges.
Well, let's look at a case
where I can't find a match.
Suppose that that
edge was missing.
We used that edge in the match.
But let's suppose
it was not there.
Let's get rid of it.
And what we find now is that
this last girl no longer
can be matched to
this second boy, which
is what we previously had.
So let's try to find
some other match.
And there isn't any.
And the reason is
that if you look
at this group of three
girls on the left
and you look at all of
the boys on the right
that they are collectively
compatible with-- that
is, one of these
three girls at least
is willing to be paired with
one of the boys on the right--
there are only
two boys that have
to be shared among three girls.
And that is one example of
what's called a bottleneck.
So we have three girls.
And collectively, they
only like two boys.
There just are not enough boys
to go around for these girls.
That proves that a match is
not going to be possible.
So more generally,
if you have a set
S of girls on the left and
you look at the image of S
under the edge
relation-- that is
E of S, which is collectively
the set of all of the boys
that are compatible with one or
more of the girls in S-- then
whenever you have--
So we previously just
had an example where S
was 3 and E of S was 2.
And because 3 was
greater than 2--
because S was greater than E
of S-- we were bottlenecked.
And we couldn't
possibly find a match.
And more generally, the
definition of a bottleneck
is that if you have a
set where the size of S
is greater than the
size of the image of S,
then that's called a bottleneck.
And the first
observation we can make
is the bottleneck lemma says
that a bottleneck is a set
S of girls without enough boys.
And if S is greater than E of
S, that's called a bottleneck.
And when there is one, no
match is possible, obviously.
So this is a reason
why there might not
be a match, is that
there is a bottleneck.
Now, a rather deep
theorem is conversely,
if there are no bottlenecks,
then in fact there is a match.
This is known as Hall's theorem.
It's not obvious,
although we'll find
an understandable proof of it.
And that's what we're going
to do in the next segment.